[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv est 7,8 pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 8 hebdo tout
de suite le titre de ce vendredi à 23
novembre
les franciliens invités à laisser leur
véhicule pour privilégier les transports
en commun la ville de paris vient
d'inaugurer et 1200 places de parking
aux portes de la capitale
l'élection municipale se déroulera en
2020 mais déjà les premiers candidats se
font connaître et notamment à trappes
guy malandain en poste depuis 2001
s'apprête à briguer un nouveau mandat
il nous expliquera les raisons en
plateau dans quelques instants et puis
au cours de la seconde partie de cet
hebdo nous ferons le point comme à
chaque fois sur l'actualité locale de la
semaine de la mobilisation des gilets
jaunes à l'installation des décorations
de noël dans les communes pour débouter
vaut débuter pardon à cette édition à un
moment toujours est symbolique la
rentrée solennelle des étudiants en
droit c'était hier soir jeudi à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et pour la première fois sur les bancs
des étudiants inscrits via la nouvelle
procédure parcours sup afin de les
préparer au mieux à leurs études une
mise à niveau
elle leur a été proposé à certains en
fonction de leur niveau justement depuis
trois semaines également présent dans
l'amphithéâtre lors de ce moment leurs
aînés qui ont brillé l'an passé écouter
la doyenne de la faculté au micro de
mano varaldo c'est une forme de joie une
joie de voir la communauté réunit
l'ensemble des collègues est en robe et
puis voir les étudiants qui sont aussi
en attente et dans la la tradition de ce
que sont nos universités qui sont des
lieux des changes de parole de liberté
parole des constructions d'un esprit
critique donc ce sont des missions
services publics qui sont pour la
société dans laquelle et à laquelle nous
appartenons qui sont vraiment
fondamental et c'est cette fierté que je
porte au moment où j'entre dans cet
amphithéâtre avec avec mes collègues
avec l'équipe administrative éducation
encore avec des plus jeunes élèves à
voisins le bretonneux on a voté ce
vendredi matin pour désigner les élus du
conseil municipal et des jeunes grégory
canal
les urnes bulletins de vote
isoloirs tous les codes d'une élection
classique sont respectées les élèves de
trois groupes scolaires de
voisins-le-bretonneux ont voté au
collège
hélène boucher vendredi 23 novembre à
l'issue du scrutin 25 enfants vont être
élu parmi une liste de candidats
jusqu'en novembre 2020 au sein du
conseil municipal des jeunes
c'est avant tout pour nous les
sensibiliser à la vie citoyenne qui est
très important bien sûr et là on
s'aperçoit que nos jeunes répondent
vraiment présent ils sont surtout je
dirais entre guillemets branché parce
qu'ils aient développement durable ce
qui est projets humanitaires ou inter
générationnelle les jeunes conseillers
municipaux se réuniront en groupe de
travail
une fois par mois une expérience qui
leur permet de débattre prendre
confiance en s'exprimant en public et
aussi de mener plusieurs projets par
exemple l'année dernière lors de la
course du printemps un événement de la
ville ou en cours avec des catégories
on a vendu des crêpes pour une
association aime la vie qui s'occupe
d'enfants porteurs de trisomie et grâce
à cet argent et l'argent les coureurs eh
ben ils ont pu partir en classe
découverte
parfois certaines idées des enfants sont
reprises par les élus adultes en conseil
municipal
tout récemment celle par exemple
d'organiser des opérations nettoyage
deux quartiers toujours des élections
municipales cette fois ci le scrutin ne
se déroulera donc qu'en 2020 dans
certaines communes elles les candidats
commencent à se faire connaître et
attrape le maire actuel va se
représenter guy malandain dont jour est
bienvenu merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation nous en prix merci de m'avoir
invité
élu pour la première fois en 2001 ce
serait votre quatrième mandat en cas de
victoire qui débuterait à 83 ans
est-ce que vous avez longuement réfléchi
avant de prendre cette décision cette
candidature réfléchie à cause de quoi
poser vos dragées puis les engagements
quatrième mandat bien entendu que que
j'ai réfléchi alors
la ville de trappes et pour moi c'est
une passion est à la fois à cause de la
qualité de ses habitants leur diversité
leur gentillesse et cgt sur le marché au
centre commercial ce matin il n'y a
pratiquement pas un seul trappistes
qu'ils soient passés à côté de massongex
ambitionnait recommence à drap et puis
moi même leur demander comment ça allait
donc c'est pour moi c'est pas un
problème partisan c'est par un problème
politicien c'est un problème de
d'attachement humains et et de voile à
damvix de continuer continuer pourquoi
c'est ça la question
pas pour ma carrière ça y est allé fait
mais continuer parce que nous avons
encore devant nous un certain nombre de
projets qui sont extrêmement important
est que je vais citer rapidement et et
qui dont les délais de mise en oeuvre ne
sont pas attachées à des décisions
municipales mais à des décisions d'ordre
national ou d'original ce sont des
projets que je je pilote entre
guillemets enfin ce que j'ai c'est
d'animer et de faire réaliser pour
certains depuis depuis 20 ans dans une
centaine à les gérer alors crissement
sur la nationale 10 et j'aimerais bien
un an peut-être que l'ex sonné par la
normale pour un élu mais j'aimerais bien
que tout ça soit très entrepris vous
voir fini quand c'est possible dans les
deux premières années 2022 voilà je ne
raconte pas d'histoires je le dis tout
net moi je parle je vais j'ai pas
l'intention de la réalisation vie
pendant passera deux premières années au
départ un mois après quoi
voilà on détente accompagné d'une équipe
de gens honnêtes respectifs fidèles
quelles sont les leçons ces projets là
il y en a qui peut étonner enfin qu'il
pourrait interroger parce que il est il
est un peu immatériel si je puis dire
c'est la mise en oeuvre de notre projet
éducatif de territoire donc j'ai dit le
mari vous a parlé quand on voit les
effets du premier pays endettés sur
l'évolution scolaire gyan entre
guillemets les évolutions personnel et
des jeunes et des enfants et des jeunes
de trappes continué me paraît absolument
évident donc il y à de l'humain là il
n'ya pas que de l'urbain le deuxième
élément sur lequel je parlais de 98 tout
à l'heure parce que j'ai fait faire des
plans pour la première fois en 98 c'est
la réalisation de du plateau urbain qui
a pour objectif bien sûr d'enfouir la
nationale et donc d'avoir un peu moins
bruit un peu moins de pollution etc
collet qui a aussi pour objectif
principal et c'est là l'essentiel pour
moi est pour moi et pour la ville risque
dans papa c'est quoi c'est de faire le
plateau urbain qui rakhmon enfants cette
ville qui depuis cinquante-trois est
coupée en deux par une faune s'auto
route et est de pouvoir revitaliser le
centre-ville avec tout ce qui se passera
autour du plateau urbain et fonciers
donc dont la ville est et est
propriétaire troisième thème ça sans
troller les énumérer tous mais on va
commencer le deuxième contrat à la fin
de l'année 2019 de rénovation urbaine ce
qu'ils sont on peut est en désaccord
avec ce que je veux dire mais quand on
voit comment la ville a été transformée
dans le pot dans le premier contrat à la
fois on domaine urbain en équilibre de
parcours de logement etc
c'est bien envie de pouvoir lancer il ya
des gens qui vont penser que je suis
prétentieux et pourquoi pas de lancer
aussi ce projet
ce projet anne rue et enfin le dernier
terme on peut je pourrais en dire plus
mais je parle des quatre une des caps
qui ont qui m'ont dit bon écoute et
malandain si voilà si les habitants le
souhaite que c'est eux qui vont décider
entre temps j'ai encore j'ai encore deux
trois ans avoue à vous offrir de mes
modestes compétences et de ma longue
expérience il dit le quatrième thème
c'est la culture
on est vraiment avec philippe guy roux
l'adjoint dans un cheminement culturel
avec avec la maîtrise avec l'opération
demos avec l'opération lully que vous
avez peut-être vu l'année dernière avec
elle à la classe spécialisée en danse et
les classes théâtre etc tout ça tout ça
est fait partie l'île
il faut encore travailler là dessus pour
que ça prenne sa pleine explosion et le
prétentieux que je suis pense que je
peux être utile encore au moins pendant
quelques temps pour vous aider tout ça
avec eux toute l'équipe et tous les
partenaires
voilà pour les raisons de votre
candidature a néanmoins sur un plan
purement politique on avait aussi ces
dernières semaines un peu d'agitation et
de déclarations des uns et des autres
sur le votre commune vous y avait
forcément été attentif et je voudrais
mentionner le cadre d'un de vos adjoints
ali rabais et qui a notamment lancé une
association qui n'a pas déclaré un être
être candidat à la mairie trappe mais en
tout cas ça y ressemble
vous avez été surpris par la création de
cette association c'est cette démarche
d'aller à la rencontre des trappistes
puis commencer la campagne en quelques
dates
alors je je vous remercie de poser cette
question
ma réponse sera que avec ce que je vous
ai dit en eau début je ne veux pas
mélanger
l'important est le dérisoire alors si la
seule réponse solide que je vous fais
par loyauté vis-à-vis de ceux qui
regardent votre chaîne et ils ont raison
de ils ont raison de le faire
c'est que je prends souvent cette image
là la marmite s'est mise à bouillir à
cette eau si je puis dire c'est la
marmite des envies des choix des
prétentions parfois et xla et j'ai été
interrogé souvent cela n'a pas beaucoup
d'importance mais moi je vais au marché
toutes les semaines dans les rues et
tout ça enfin ça c'est ma manière de
d'être et les habitants de sa vie j'ai
tiré j'ai été étonnée d'être interrogé
aussi depuis la fin puis les moments de
juillet-août et presque elle pendant les
vacances alors est ce que est ce que
monsieur le maire vous vous restez avec
nous ils sont passionnés vous restez
avec nous et donc comme je dis bon on
verra ça plus tard
on n'est pas dans l'urgence excusez moi
d'être trop simple oui mais on a encore
16 mois à faire de boulot pour la ville
au delà de tout le reste
et ça c'est un devoir de le faire on est
et donc je dis bon allez je me dis leur
que tu as envie de continuer c'est ce
que j'ai fait donc le dire les rapports
qui sortait de la cocotte-minute mal
fermée ont fait précipiter l'annoncent
ne pas changer le contenu et les raisons
de la non ce
voilà néanmoins vous en avez discuté ou
pas avec cet adjoint en question elle
ira mais lui dit qu'il vous en avait
parlé de nos commandes ne souhaitait pas
commenter plus très bien en tout cas on
a senti que si quand vous allez
présenter plutôt votre nouvelle
candidature il sera pas forcément sur
votre liste
nous avait déjà constitué cette liste en
double un nom nous non est-ce qu'elle
sera renouvelée est ce que vous allez
parce qu'il va vous ici falloir passer
la main vous m'avez dit vous même jour
deux autres oiseaux demanda donc vous
avez déjà en tête quelqu'un pour vous
succéder peut-être que oui mais je
durée passant donc ça vous ennuie pas
bien et donc quelle est la trajectoire
d'abord d'abord on finit trop continue
le travail et les responsabiliser que
l'on a je disais tout à l'heure
sans s'occuper de sa petite carrière
personnelle nous sommes élus par les
habitants pour servir les habitants et
la ville
ça c'est essentiel ceux qui ne croient
pas en sa il faut qu'il change de
politique bien
le deuxième élément c'est que nous avons
déjà organisé nos méthodes nos méthodes
de travail puisque le décision est prise
et que tous les amis qui le à qui le
souhaite le savent et commencera après
après les vacances les grandes vacances
n'ont pas un travail interne et mon
travail externe après les grandes
vacances de l'année prochaine parce que
nous sommes aujourd'hui responsable de
la gestion de la ville et puis qu'on
n'est pas encore au mois de mars 2020 à
savoir d'ailleurs que c'est possible que
devrait les pousser aussi fonction des
résultats des élections européennes et
non la décision de décaler certains
justement il ya eu des précédents déjà
déjà arrivé effectivement c'était génial
et qui guy malandain merci d'être venu
répondre à nos questions je vous propose
de rester encore quelques instants en
prime la voix qui vous remercie
nous allons revenir sur l'actualité de
la semaine à présent
[Musique]
et dans l'actualité de cette semaine la
mobilisation des gilets jaunes qui
perdure le département devrait être
encore être touché ce week-end retour
sur les points de blocage et les
revendications avec ce reportage
[Musique]
les gilet jaune signe de ralliement des
français mécontents du prix des
carburants ont manifesté dans les
yvelines
la mobilisation a commencé samedi 17
novembre au matin avec l'opération
escargot de saint nom la bretèche qui a
été rejoint par les manifestants venus
de rambouillet rassemblement également
sur le secteur de ville propre plaisir
les motards ont tous vers le convoi
l'ardente ça se faisait mon plein de 68
pour 45 euros
maintenant on est serein on est sur un
45 bay 60 euros donc chaque révolution
la zone commerciale des clayes-sous-bois
était bloqué par petits groupes les
manifestants traverse les passages
piétons pour bloquer les conducteurs
derrière ce mouvement d gilet jaune se
cache diverses revendications d'abord
celle des automobilistes
exaspérés par la hausse des taxes sur le
carburant mais aussi celle des salariés
qui voient les coûts de la vie augmenter
depuis des années des années les
salaires ils sont bloqués ils sont
jeunes et mêmes ils diminuent alors
aujourd'hui bas on travaille on
travaille toujours plus mais c'est pour
gagner moi alors là du coup il y en a
ras-le-bol
parmi les gilet jaune le site des futurs
retraités dont le pouvoir d'achat est
impacté par la hausse de la csg
ça fait moins des années que je
travaille je vais arriver à la retraite
j'ai 1500 euros de salaire donc je vais
me retrouver avec une retraite de 1200
euros
eh bien avec ça on vit pas et quand il
me faut qu'ils viennent nous expliquer
ce qu'ils décident de continuer à me
faire les poches
comment vit avec sa suite aux
mobilisations la gendarmerie a décidé de
fermer l'a13 au niveau du triangle de
rocquencourt
les manifestants se sont ensuite tous
donné rendez vous sur le parking d'une
discothèque à louveciennes qu'il faut se
faire comprendre
à partir du moment où on fait que
d'augmenter les prix nous on en a
ras-le-bol eux c'est bien
you li nous inquiète 6 5 et 6 encaissés
mais nous on est déjà dans la merde à
partir du moment où on est déjà dans la
merde ils peuvent pas mieux nous foute
six pieds sous terre
les gilet jaune mécontents des annonces
du gouvernement espère que ce mouvement
sera prolongée et lance un nouvel appel
à bloquer paris samedi 24 novembre
guy malandain je dois vous faire réagir
sur ces gilet jaune justement cette
colère vous la comprenez vous l'entendez
vous aussi
moi je je pense que il y à des réformes
politiques qui sont obligatoires si vous
ne les fait pas ça nous coûtera encore
plus cher entre guillemets après ce qui
manque aujourd'hui beau semble-t-il
c'est un avis c'est pas un jugement de
procureur s'est vu dire ce qui ce qui
manque aujourd'hui c'est une
compréhension de la méthode de
l'organisation et à mon avis il ya trop
de précipitation et de décisions qui
sont prises dont le fondement peut avoir
des racines justifiée mais dont la
compréhension ne peut pas être fait de
cette manière là par les habitants
d'autre part il ya une donnée réelle qui
ne date pas forcément de des deux
dernières années il faut être honnête
été regardé une globalité c'est que
petit à petit décision après décision
recherche des équilibres budgétaires
nationales après recherche d'exeter
accepte enfin de me dire que la finance
a appris sûrement trop de place elle est
nécessaire il faut la regarder
hélas pris trop de place par rapport au
social à l'épanouissement et et
finalement au bonheur de chacun mais moi
je vois sur la ville de trappes
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui alors ne faisons
pas comme ça des histoires
moi je suis plus membre d'un parti
politique parce que je comprend plus
très bien où il faut aller mais je suis
un républicain de gauche tout le monde
le sait ont créé sur mes idées
faisons faisons un grenelle
d'aujourd'hui chacun connaît un peu
cette histoire comment les confites mai
68 sont terminées tout le monde autour
de la table on travaille et on se
on se bloque
je veux dire on dépense son énergie sur
des réalités pas sur des théories
financières ou des théories des
techniques alors est ce que est ce que
je veux dire bloquer tout le monde
pendant une semaine ça conduira à ça je
suis pas sûr je le souhaite en tout cas
que l'idée soit on se lève et se
restaurer autour de laquelle ils ont
discuté retour à la table on se dit
voilà on a un mois de négociations en
france par truqués puis on dit là voilà
comment on fait il ya un accord ou ya
pas d accord sur tout mais il y a
participation est prise en compte de
d'une évolution assez assez forte quand
même de de la pauvreté au sens
inacceptable du terme voilà c'est en
tout cas c'est sur la ville c'est ce
qu'on vit est le cas à la fois
renouvellement socio-économique mais
hier encore de nombreuses familles qui
ont vraiment pas grand chose pour vivre
merci beaucoup guy malandain venus
participer à cette suite hebdo et donc
je le rappelle officiellement candidat
pour les municipales de 2020 en même
temps on en reparlera bien sûr nous
poursuivons ce résumé de la semaine avec
un chantier d'envergure des images rares
également le premier tronçon de la
grande passerelle reliant
mantes-la-jolie ali mais pour les
piétons et cyclistes a été posée en
début de semaine opération
particulièrement délicate regarder il
est arrivé sur une barge
le premier tronçon de la grande
passerelle a pris place l'un des 19
novembre sur le pont reliant la place de
l'étape à mantes-la-jolie au théâtre de
verdure de l'île aux dames c'est une
une opération extrêmement délicate qui
prend 48 heures pendant 48 euros qu'une
péniche ne passera sur ce bras de seine
pour pouvoir faciliter cette
installation 105 mètres de long et 7 m
de large pour une passerelle total de
201 m réservé aux piétons et aux
cyclistes
elle entre dans un projet global en
faveur de la mobilité douce de 9,6
millions d'euros financé en majorité par
la région ile de france le département
des yvelines a contribué à 11%
la mise en route de cette passerelle
correspond à cette volonté de faire que
ce lieu traditionnel de passage d'une
rive à l'autre remplisse toutes les
fonds de chaud qui sont les siennes dans
la société d'aujourd'hui
la structure est en acier et elle est
revêtue de bois l'architecte l'a imaginé
comme une terrasse reliant le centre
ville de mantes la jolie et de l'hymne i
télé les décès mais en rapport avec le
point existant qui est un pont routier
qui est un endroit en fait assez assez
lourd assez présente dans le site nous
c'est le léger on se savait d'où cv un
peu justement ambulante pour être en
harmonie avec le fleuve avec le paysage
le chantier devrait prendre fin à l'est
vers 2019 cette passerelle correspond à
la première étape du nouveau
franchissement entre les deux villes le
vieux pont situé de l'autre côté sera
rénové et agrémenté lui aussi d'une
passerelle
les deux ouvrages seront ensuite relié
par un cheminement piéton et cyclable
sur l'île aux dames elles ont déjà pris
place dans les rues en un peu plus d'un
mois des fêtes de noël les illuminations
étaient installés c'est le cas à
montigny le bretonneux des milliers de
leds qui à la nuit tombée se parent de
couleurs comme de nombreuses villes
montigny le bretonneux n'a pas attendu
le mois de décembre pour les installer
on n'a pas en interne le personnel et le
matériel nécessaire à la pauvre qui doit
se faire sur un laps de temps très court
on a démarré en octobre
il faut que ça soit fini pour le 29
novembre juste avant le week-end du
marché noël c'est le marché noël qui
donne le top de la mise en place pour
proposer des décorations différent
chaque année la commune les loups à une
société extérieure pour un coût de 100
milles aux 240 motifs sont répartis dans
toute la ville il nous reste quelques
motifs dont les motifs 3d en trois
dimensions qui seront installés sur le
sur l'avenue du pas du lac kir au niveau
du rond-point l'invs skywest et au
niveau de l'hôtel de ville tous les
quartiers sont sont desservis les laisse
les centres commerciaux on lé byin bien
sûr les nos bâtiments publics l'hôtel de
ville en priorité plus que quelques
jours d'installation et les décorations
illumineront les soirées in i monteyne
jusqu'à la fin des fêtes
[Musique]
le 7-8 hebdo sur tv 78 c'est aussi
l'occasion de regarder au delà des
frontières du département nos confrères
de via grand paris chaîne disponible sur
la tnt reviennent aujourd'hui sur la
mise en place de parkings relais en ile
de france afin de limiter le nombre de
véhicules au sein de paris intra muros
la ville de paris a présenté le
dispositif place relais près de 1200
places de parking répartis dans onze
parcs de stationnement situé aux portes
de la capitale seront accessibles dès le
1er décembre pour 75 euros par mois
l'idée d'inciter des automobilistes à
laisser leur véhicule à l'entrée de
paris afin de privilégier le métro tout
en luttant contre la pollution de l'air
je veux contribuer aussi à faciliter la
mobilité
des franciliens et à lutter en même
temps contre la pollution de l'air ça
c'est le grand enjeu le grand défi
auquel nous sommes confrontés
ce dispositif est exclusivement réservé
aux personnes possédant pass navigo
mais ce n'est pas tout pour y être
éligible il faut que le domicile du
demandeur réussite de l'employeur ne
soit pas à proximité du parc de
stationnement
la carte grise quant à elle ne doit pas
être celle d'un véhicule de société ou
de fonction des discussions avec la
région vont bientôt avoir lieu afin que
la carte de stationnement intègre le
pass navigo
on aura sans doute dans les mois qui
viennent
région ile-de-france qui permettra de
d'avoir une seule carte la carte du
passe navigo pour pouvoir y mettre son
abonnement au parking relais et son
abonnement pour la mobilité à
l'intérieur de la ville
en cas de forte demande des places
supplémentaires pourrait voir le jour
et après ce coup d'oeil dans le reste de
l'actualité de l'île de france retour à
saint quentin avec notre autre rendez
vous du week end ça s'est passé nous
ouvrons les archives de tv 78 retour sur
l' affaire des faux espions au
technocentre renault alors que la sphère
carlos ghosn prend de l'ampleur
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les trois cadres mis à pied lundi
travaillait au technocentre de
guyancourt
ils sont soupçonnés d'avoir diffusé à
l'extérieur des informations sur les
projets de véhicules électriques un
dossier stratégique est un enjeu énorme
pour renault et son allié japonais
nissan
joint par téléphone ce jeudi après midi
le responsable de la communication au
technocentre confirmait ces éléments en
précisant que la procédure en cours
portaient sur des actes sérieux
en revanche il insistait sur un
traitement de la sphère disproportionnée
selon lui en regrettant notamment que
nos confrères du parisien et publié le
nom et la photo des trois cadres
concernés
on ne peut rien dire en interne car le
droit du travail s'applique et l'
enquête est en cours
du côté des représentants des salariés
au technocentre denis de dieu de la cfdt
joint par téléphone affirment avoir
découvert à la faire dans la presse
comme tout le monde
ce n'est que ce jeudi matin soit trois
jours après les faits que le numéro deux
du groupe patrick pelata s'est adressé à
l'ensemble des collaborateurs par un
courrier pour mettre un terme aux
rumeurs
ils demandent leur discrétion et leur
réserve sur cette affaire pourquoi ils
ont attendu le premier jour de l'année
un pur pour sanctionner les salariés un
devoir le service sécurité
un débarqué dans le technocentre et puis
ramenée à l'extérieur les jambons tout
le monde se pose des questions c'est
qu'il sait c'est qu'il prochain quoi on
peut se poser aussi légitimement ce type
de problème est sacré quand même une
ambiance étiez pas folichonne
les saints la formation elle a eu on est
c'est à dire ce sont des informations
qui ont été communiquées par la presse
nous ce que l'on demande notamment à
rouleaux c'est de rencontrer les
organisations syndicales projet beaucoup
plus de précision pour l'instant trois
personnes soit mise à pied conservatoire
pour nous ils sont pressurés présumé
pour l'instant innocents nous parle de
l'espionnage ou parle d'un tas de choses
et que les médias comédie avant que les
salariés et les salariés dans faut
réformer ça nous paraît quand même pas
très logique
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition de votre
journal de fin de semaine autour de
l'actualité est lundi très bon week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]